[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا مرحبا بكم الى هذه الجوله
الجديده في الصحف نبداها باهتماماتيه
الصحفيه العربيه وقمه بغداد الاثنين التي
تنطلقوا اليوم في الاردن
الملك عبد الله الثاني وبحضوره الرئيسيه
الفرنسيه ايمانيه
[موسيقى]
العراقيه التي تقول ان القمه ستكون
بمشاركه 11 دوله ومع تمثيل الاسلاميين
واوروبي ومنظمات اقليميه التنميه والامن
والشراكه تتصدر قمه الاردن وايران فرصه
لتحريك مباحثات النووي هذه هذا التصريح هو
التصريح لوزير الخارجيه الايراني
همم صحيفه همم العرب تقول ان همم ان
الكلام كثيرا علي التطبيعه السعوديه
الايراني والعداء على حاله ايران تحتاج
الى التطبيع مع السعوديه لكن المملكه لا
تبدي رغبه في هذا الشان بسبب مناورات
طهران المتكرره والصحيفه تحينا اذا الى
تصريحاتي وزير الخارجيه الايراني ليوم امس
عندما عندما اكد ان بلاده تسعى الى
تطبيعيه علاقاتها مع السعوديه
صحيفه الراي الاردنيه تقول ان مؤتمر
بغدادي يلتئم في البحريه الميتيه اليوم
كما تعنن الصحيفه
على الاشتباكات التي دارت امس بين بين
افراد من الشرطه
الاردنيه وعناصر ارهابيه وتقول
اذا عن ونتي الصحيفه كذلك على هذه
المواجهه الداميه
وضعت على الغلاف سوره
عناصر الشرطه الذين لقوا حدفهم امس وكتبتي
الصحيفه في الافتتاحيه ان
الارهابيين قد جاوزوا المدى وهدفهم اشعاله
الفتنه وايقاع البلدي في فخريه الفوضى
صحيفه والدستور الاردني
كذلك على قمه بغداد اثنين كما عن ولد على
تشيع جثامنيه افراد الامن الثلاث وقالت
ولي العهد يشارك بتشيعش الثامن شهداء
الامن
والاردنيون يقولون ان ما يحدث ما يحدث قتل
مع سبق الاصرار وليس حريات الاردنيون اذا
يجمعون على امني الوطن
ونبذيه التطرف وفي موضوع اخر مشاهدين
موضوع زياره الرئيس الروسي الذي مربوطين
الى بيلاروسيا ولقائه بالرئيس الكسندر
لوكاشينكو هذا هذه الصفحه من الشرقيه
الاوسط تقول انهما اتخذ خطوه مشتركه
لمواجهتي العقوبات وانفتاح على الحوار مع
الغرب تفاهم على تعزيز التعاونيه العسكري
وتوسيعه همم البرنامج النووي البيلاروسي
ووضع اليات مشتركه لمواجهه الضغوط الغربيه
المتساعده همم على
لديهما صحيفه
تقول ان الزياره ان زياره الرئيسيه
الروسيه الى بيلاروسيا تثير المخاوف من
الجرب الى روسيا الى الحرب ضد اوكرانيا
وصحيفه العربيه الجديد تقول ان هذه الحرب
تسببت في ازمه في الطاقه في اوروبا وقالت
ان الطاقه صارت كابوسه اوروبا
همم اذا همم
وما وصفته اذا كذلك الصحيفه بالكارثه التي
ربما تكون في بدايتها مع تصاعدي البردي
موجه البرد واستمراريه الحرب اذا في
اوكرانيا صحيفه تقول لنا ان 10 اشهر مره
على الحرب على الاشتياح
الروسيه لاوكرانيا مع مع سبل سبل همم
الوصول الى اتفاق التي تبقى
مغلقات في ما يدفع المدنيون اذا الثمن همم
الاكبر في هذه الحرب وبعيدا المشاهدين عن
اجواء الحرب نتحول اذا الى اجواء كره
القدم وصول همم المنتخب
الفرنسي ليله البارحه همم الى الى باريس
صحيفه همم
الشعبيه الفرنسيه
تصفوهم بتصف لاعب المنتخب الفرنسي
بالاساطير وتقول شكرا للاساطير بعد
الادائي المتميز الذي حققوه امام رفاقي
ميسي وصحيفه لوفي تقول وانه وبعد الملحمه
التي انجزوها اذا في قطر همم
في قطريه ما احلى لاعبوا المنتخب الفرنسي
للاستعداد لخوض بطوله الامم الاوروبيه
التي ستقام في المانيا في العام
2024 صحيفه الفرنسيه تعود على اعلان كريم
بنزيما اللاعب همم
الفرنسي همم اعلان هو اعتزاله دوليا همم
هذا ما هذا فيما همم يطمح
ومدرب المنتخب الفرنسي الى
اذا في منصبه
شريطه تمديد عقده همم الى مونديال 2006
و20 على الجانبيه الارجنتيني اذا على
الجانب الارجنتيني عاد المنتخب
والارجنتيني همم الى بلاده كذلك وخصص له
استقبال تاريخي واعلنتي السلطات اليوم يوم
عيد وطني وصحيفه اذا صحيفه المختصه في
شؤون الرياضيات
اعاده الاب همم ليونيل تقديسا للاعب
ليونيل ميسي وعد كذلك او سيعود همم
المنتخب المغربي اليوم كذلك الى بلاده بعد
الانجاز التاريخيه الذي حققه في مونديال
قطر وصحيفه لمتى المغربيه تقول ان العاهله
المغربي سيخسس له همم تك انه مراسمه تكريم
واحتفال اعترافا بالانجاز التاريخيه الذي
حققه في قطر وهكذا انهي مشاهدينا جوله
تنافيه الصحف لهذا اليوم دم بخير الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]